you hear this claim made a lot
Republicans are the party of the rich
okay then that would mean for
Republicans to win any election ever it
is in their best interest to keep all
Americans what what rich and if
Democrats only when the poor vote it
would be in their best interest to
maintain what what what more poor
Americans which party do you want
looking out for your finances question
of the day do you see yourself better or
worse off than when President Trump took
office financially how do you see the
state of the country you know right
right now a lot of people trying to make
the case that the economy isn't doing as
well as we all know it is things seem
more difficult under the Obama miss what
would it take to convince you that
Donald Trump has been bad for the
economy I would really like to know I
don't know how they're going to spin
this the left right now that the economy
is not rip-roaring so but let me let me
kind of let's set some context here
impeachment okay impeachment was a
disaster to begin with yeah right for
the Democrats Trump is now headed into
2020 he's he's been acquitted he has
America enjoying perhaps that I would
argue and you could argue gets it let me
know the strongest economy of all time
so you can see in this letter that
circulated that Democrats are not trying
to convince people figure out any way
how to convince people that the economy
isn't actually as good as the economy
actually is so let's go through a few
lies that they're going to be trying to
sell and I've seen this a lot so
recently the New York Times claimed this
I think that's right we have an overlay
and Obama even tweeted out suggesting
this idea that he can take credit for
president Trump's
job growth hmm and of course President
Trump responded by calling Barack
Obama's claims a con job he noted that
President Obama had the slowest recovery
from a recession since the Great
Depression so what's the truth here
because I know some people aren't
necessarily nerdy or wonkish and you
only really know what you feel and polls
show us that people feel as though the
economy is better but what are the
numbers show us okay
the truth is that Obama's economy it did
it recovered from a recession and you
have to acknowledge that so you could
argue that President Trump is continuing
that because anything short of another
recession would be a continuation of
technically Barack Obama taking us out
of recession so for you
there you go what a scoreboard for you
but president Trump is right and that
it's a con job we'll get into a bit more
depth of that later it was short-lived
it was it was very stupidly it was one
of the slowest recoveries ever in
history while President Donald Trump has
brought with him record-breaking booming
economy by almost and this is important
by almost every metric available you'll
see a lot of people in left try and say
well GDP doesn't necessarily affect the
average everyday American one of you
heard us arguing
maybe in addendum to all the numbers of
course everybody individually and of
course GDP doesn't matter but no it's
every metric that we have available okay
here pick a metric any metric yes that
one
so if President Trump will use if he was
just going to be continuing the Obama
trends this is something that I always
find odd now this is what they're
claiming if they all believe that then
why did every single leftist economist
commentator and their dog and pet ferret
claim that the trends not only would
cease but that it would be impossible to
continue them even more than that I
think was a Krugman it was a bunch of
people it's usually it always Krugman
today would crash do you remember when
he claimed that Donald Trump couldn't
create any new jobs and he was asking if
Donald Trump was well here just just
watch this clip he's gonna bring all
these jobs back well how exactly are you
gonna do that what are you gonna do cut
taxes there's there's no answer to it he
just says well I'm gonna I'm gonna go
she ate a better deal well ha what how
exactly are you willing to negotiate
that I what magic wand do you have first
off it's a white magic word what you did
the opposite and this is something else
that we've also we've also heard this
argument you're going to see the
Democrats try and spin it this way going
into 2020 I want you to be equipped to
know all these arguments yeah they start
with the premise because it's undeniable
that unemployment is at an all-time low
not to mention the labor force
participation rate but even then they go
okay unemployment is low that looks bad
for us we can't rejoice in a booming
American economy we have to make an
excuse and so now you see a lot of those
on the Left saying it doesn't matter
because the jobs are just crap it's the
way it's
McDonald's Burger King Wendy's that's
what it is and greeters yeah unless
people start asking hey jobs Amazon's
best economy ever one of those wages
we're not get those answers because it's
gonna become a political campaign father
against him trust disco predator on this
one folks are you sure there's anyone
like this we said we can still see you
disco predator that limb is not covered
so this is there any evidence that all
of the jobs present Trump is at it that
they don't pay we hear there's anything
and this is like a lot of things right
it's basically it's a citation of a
citation of a reference and no one
really knows where it's coming from so
let me kind of get to the root the root
of this or at least from what I've seen
because I've tried to comb through this
and its really pretty paper-thin but I
know that they're going to be pushing it
again going into 2020 the Brookings
Institute disappointed me surely with
this but then you realize you can still
have crazy people who work at you know
reputable Institute's they released a
study and the study was claiming that
the low unemployment numbers up there
aren't anything to celebrate why because
the jobs don't pay okay they even went
as far as to claim that a huge swath of
hardworking Americans I think like 53
million Americans they make only $18,000
per year you can go and I highly
encourage you to read this study and
look at the methodology I know this
might be hard for a lot of you to
understand since the median household
income for middle income families is up
five thousand dollars under President
Trump compared to only up one thousand
dollars throughout the entirety of
Barack Obama's eight years here's why
this is important to this study since
this is what everyone is is citing as
far as if someone knows something else
this is the most legitimate study that I
could find only half of the people in
this analysis even work full-time I
think the actual numbers at 50 57
percent that's right here's my question
why include those people at all why
include the part-time workers at all
that means that 43 percent could be
working any amount of hours there's no
minimum set so this is a sampling of
mind you have only 53 million Americans
according to their methodology but
really that's only about 30 million
Americans when you take into account the
people who are working full-time
we have no idea as to what the average
wage is for those full time workers
because of that average being pulled
down by part-timers how is this a valid
analysis for in any way informative and
I want to be careful here because you
see sometimes people who don't
necessarily understand numbers or can't
be bothered with research and they say
well there are lies damn lies and
statistics like okay we get it that you
can quote Mark Twain I think it was a
Mark Twain but here's the thing the
spirit if the spore if I should say if
the spirit when you're conducting an
economic study right if the spirit is to
accurately assess the economic
opportunity for the average full-time
American worker right if your goal is to
find out how everyday Americans are
actually doing if you truly care about
them why would you include millions of
kids working their way through college
at fifteen hours a week it couldn't be
less relevant it absolutely it's it's
clear as day that you're going into this
with an agenda by the way speaking of
agenda hit the notification bell hit all
notifications on you too it's a good one
because subscriptions don't mean
anything and please do consider joining
my club at ladder with better calm slash
mug club you get access to a full daily
show not available on YouTube but we do
have new clips new videos every single
day 9:00 p.m. Eastern so just check in
because subscriptions suck the reason if
you look at the methodology of the study
is it removes the ability for someone to
see the class mobility through the
statistics it has a kid who is in
college who's working 15 hours is not
going to be doing that for a long time
that's why it's more important to look
at the average income increase for
Americans the average job the average
hourly wage increase has been incredible
by the way growth that we haven't seen
before that's not even accurate metric
but by the leftist metrics it's doing
better and here's something else to that
they also claim while we're talking
about this that it doesn't really matter
if we include part-time jobs or not
because now there are so many people who
have to work multiple jobs just to make
ends meet here you go we look at these
figures and we say Oh unemployment is
low everything is fine right well
unemployment is low because everyone has
two jobs well it's it you can just say
that but even politifact rated the claim
pants on fire and they really the
highest-rated
highest rating the fact-checker and
they'll enhance on fire on fire we're
gonna do come out and image your
national watermelon with a mallet like
the Academy is booming I don't trust you
PolitiFact just doesn't seem legitimate
I know the irony and you're talking
about a guy who dresses up like a dame
to make a joke it works this is another
confirmation this is what they trying to
do is say this is relative and really
Barack Obama was better at adding jobs
and President Trump to the economy
relatively and you see them Democrats
specifically touting Barack Obama adding
more jobs in a certain period than
Donald Trump this is the claim you'll
hear yeah I'll show you some charts and
then we can go through some other things
he said in his speech that were also
quite incredible but let's start with
job growth and he bragged a lot about
the job growth but as you can see here
what we're trying to show here is that
job growth under President Trump which
has been significant was actually lower
than job growth under President Obama
over the same 35 months the end of
Obama's term versus the beginning of
Trump's term so the idea that there's
something unprecedented happening here
as well as ridiculous take it from
progeria Rick Moranis all the characters
can't be happy these people can't be you
feel bad for laughing at that at home
but you shouldn't you shouldn't let you
feel good about yourself it's a stupid
comparison for so many reasons ok so let
me walk you through this a little bit
you can say that this is me opining sure
but I want to present some empirical
data Obama's economy right he came in
after the housing crash so the highest
unemployment on record was nearing 10
percent right or as they refer to it in
Europe good have you complained about
gas try to Montreal for a day see what
they're paying over there you imagine
what they pay in Europe when you talk
about wanting to vilify the fossil fuel
industries fill up your tank and Sweden
then get back to me so it's easy though
to add jobs when you have massive
unemployment you're coming off of a
recession as a matter of fact it's
expected right what we have under
President Trump is really different what
you have right now is the lowest
unemployment on record and he's still
adding huge amounts of jobs right now
after we hit the record low unemployment
of course in taken
from 10% down to 7% 6% that would
obviously be good but you would expect
it to go down from the abnormal 10% as
abnormal for Americans that the US have
that kind of unemployment but when you
were down at 5% unemployment and you're
still adding record jobs that matters of
the question that's most relevant with
Barack Obama is how did the economy
recover it turns out it was it was I
don't trumpet right one of the slowest
ever on record yeah slower than the
average 4% growth that would be normal
for the United States economy right
slower than george w bush's 2.7 percent
economic growth which people were not
happy with just now idly so in fact the
GDP growth under Obama was the slowest
ever that we have now even CNN admits
this I'm not only talking about GDP but
I do think that it matters again you can
go back to look at all the numbers that
affect you your average income the
amount of layoffs the labor force
participation what kind of economic
opportunity there is out there the cost
of inflation you can look at the cost of
drugs that when you adjust for inflation
if today I've actually come down for the
first time ever in my lifetime these are
things that affect you GDP does matter
in a global scale but it's certainly not
the only metric that we use pick a
metric find one that would show you that
Donald Trump's president Donald Trump's
economy is not doing well here's what
you need to know we do have to go in a
second these are these are the fast
facts that you need to know unemployment
all-time low layoffs all-time low again
not just focusing on GDP on the average
American there is more job opportunity
in the last decade than there have ever
been and certainly at higher wages the
average middle-income American family
have seen the biggest increase that
they've seen in half a century the exact
opposite of Barack Obama during the
first few years of Obama's presidency
the media preached his economy they
talked about how well it was doing most
Americans you this is where I want to
hear from you weren't feeling it and you
can look at that as as to where
Americans were investing what they were
buying what their purchasing power was
now President Trump is doing well and
most Americans when asked are feeling it
undeniably repeatedly Americans are
saying that they are better off now than
they were six years ago but and this is
what you need to know the most or at
least what you need to keep your eyes
peeled for the media wants you to
believe the exact opposite which begs it
begs the question when the economy and
the average American when they're doing
under nine
doubly well in comparison to last
several decades and Nancy Pelosi Bernie
Sanders the DNC in their media cronies
are dead set on getting you to believe
the opposite who do you really think is
looking out for you who wants you to be
successful versus who wants to buy votes
I think that's important final thing
I'll leave you with if Democrats need
the poor as a voting base and
Republicans need the rich as a voting
base again this is simplified logic but
you hear this claim made a lot
Republicans are the party of the rich
okay then that would mean for
Republicans to win any election ever it
is in their best interest to keep all
Americans what what rich and if
Democrats only when the poor vote it
would be in their best interest to
maintain what what what more poor
Americans which party do you want
looking out for your finances guess who
I am
I'm Josh Hartnett bet you didn't think
you'd see that face in a while this is
what we call an end card which is where
I tell you that you should subscribe if
you like this video or click one of
these other videos that you may like hit
the notification bell of course join mug
club because that's what allows us to
continue doing these videos and just so
you know YouTube actually is created a
new policy where they might start
outright banning channels that are no
longer commercially viable which means
that this is merely a figment of your
imagination